we have Team coverage on several
political stories tonight we start at
Cheyenne High School where former
president Barack Obama is about to
campaign for local Democrats Victoria
Saha is there Victoria
yeah Denise and John there's a huge
crowd here at the gymnasium here at
Cheyenne High School so many of these
folks eager to see former President
Obama and many other big names who are
set to take the podium later tonight
along with the former president artist
John Legend and activist Dolores Huerta
is also set to make an appearance this
rally comes just seven days before the
midterm elections to encourage votes for
governor Steve sisolak and Senator
Catherine Cortez masto who both are
expected to be here tonight as well one
woman I spoke to explained why she came
out tonight
I just love everything about him his
professionalism I mean it's something
that we're not getting today so I
definitely miss that
[Applause]
[Music]
now this is all part of the former
president's cross-country tour rallying
supports for the Democrats ahead of the
midterm elections which is of course
next week this event is set to start at
about 6 45 tonight reporting live from
Cheyenne High School Victoria Saha 8
news now Victoria thank you now during
this election season former president
Donald Trump has made two stops here in
Nevada he's been supporting Republican
Senate candidate Adam laxalt and
Republican gubernatorial candidate Joe
Lombardo in response to former President
Obama's visit the Republican National
Committee released this statement quote
you know Democrats are desperate when
they bring out former president Obama to
campaign for them this late in the game
Silver State Democrats the statement
continues no they're about to be out of
a job and his presence makes it clear
they're running scared and the final
days of their doomed campaigns